[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum thank you for
listening again joining us uh you know
Ryan welcome welcome good to see you oh
thank you yeah no I gotta be here you
know I I never listen to the episodes I
never ever ever do but I listened to the
Pete Holmes episode yeah and I actually
enjoyed it it was a good time right yeah
I actually enjoyed it I was like hey
this was a fun interview I wasn't like
you know completely turned off by my
voice which was nice I thought I was
gonna be like oh God shut the f up but
uh I really enjoyed it and uh I hope
you're enjoying the podcast if you're
here for Harvey Gian I hope that if you
like the podcast I'll ask you is if you
could subscribe write a review it really
helps the podcast so hey we're the
little podcast that could
um our socials if you want to follow us
which are important are Ryan uh at
inside of you pod on Twitter inside of
you podcast on Instagram and Facebook
that's true I just picked my nose a
little bit oh nice I also want to
support some things that I'd love
um the animal rescue mission rescues
rehabs and finds forever homes for
abused and neglected animals go to
theanimalrescuemission.org tell Shira
Rosenbaum says hello uh also
foodonfoot.org for the homeless
situation in Los Angeles which is is
terrible and you could help them out and
donate or The Echoes of Hope
uh dot org I think echoesofhope.org for
the um Foster youth helping Foster youth
all over Los Angeles and that truly
helps
three great companies three great
organizations non-profits if you will
um so I'll say that also if you want to
join patreon join patreon and support
the show without patreon I don't think
the show would be going so go to
patreon.com inside of you and I'll
message you back if you become a a
patron and that's pretty much it
um I I to the top tiers I send boxes of
merch every four months with a little
note you get your name read off at the
end of every show there's YouTube lives
with me q and A's there's like a lot of
great stuff bonus episodes so go to
patreon.com
inside of you and of course the inside
of you online store tons of awesome
merch and Smallville stuff and
autographs and tumblers and check it out
the inside of your online store today's
guest
Harvey Gyan from another great one oh
man
he is such a great guy what we do in the
shadows if you haven't seen the show we
really it was an emotional Journey was
this a great story about him and his mom
and you know him coming out and how hard
that was and and
um you know it's it's nice to hear
people open up because there's a lot of
people listening that probably have
dealt with similar situations he's just
a great soul I loved having him here and
we talked really about everything and so
why don't we just get to it why don't we
get inside of Harvey again it's my point
of view
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenberg
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience you're commenting on all my
toys and my gadgets and my posters and
my bobble heads I like it I I'm I love
going to like spaces and seeing I like
when a place looks like there's a story
so I feel like there's a story to all
the pieces here so there's a
conversation to be had they're my
friends
my doodles are my friends
I actually made a little short film with
some friends that was called child it's
about a giant child
um and he doesn't stop growing and the
parents are played by kids and I played
the child and you can find it but it's a
it's a cool little fairy tale short but
he just never you know he grows up too
fast he gets too big too fast he's eight
years old and he's a giant right and it
was really fun it was really uh I don't
know why I told you that I like that
where's that poster you should have a
poster for it should I have the gel I do
have a child poster somewhere I just
didn't put it up are you a horror movie
fan
yeah I like horror I like slasher
Thrillers
um yeah I like it I like it puppets yeah
it's definitely Krueger's hands that's
Freddy Krueger's hand
see see if people are listening they're
gonna probably go back and watch it
because they wanna although they won't
see it oh they wouldn't see Freddy
Krueger's hand you could just see my
facial expressions seeing everything
I've seen yeah that's true yeah so where
do we meet
where do we meet I think we met at a con
Comic-Con do we meet at a con yeah I
think we made a car no wait we
officially met
um and it was it was actually it was
cool because it was it was a first date
but it was to see you in your show what
do you mean for me my stand-up yeah
you're opening or doing something your
buddies with them and and they had a set
and then I met you that day by
association but it was like the date and
like it was me and you and then we went
to like Barney's Beanery afterwards yeah
uh yeah and it was uh but yeah so we
kind of met that way like a soft meet
Soft Meet was it uncomfortable was it
what is it was it no you were lovely you
were great no it was it was it was a fun
date it was just not what I thought it
would be which you think it would be
like dinner in a movie I thought so it
was like dinner movie or something and
it was like yeah the set gonna see uh
which is by the way we're not seeing who
this person is but they're wonderful one
wonderful person uh lovely lovely
comedian uh and it's just uh yeah so
it's like that's how we met that's what
we met and then kinda through like you
know
the Comic-Con circuit how do you like
The Comic Cons I like them I think I'm
the only one in my cast who likes them
um I just I don't know I think for so
long you know I grew up in LA and going
to Comic Con San Diego was so expensive
and you put like all your effort into
going and you really wanted to see those
actors or whoever you idolized at those
events so you would go as a fan I
couldn't when I was I was so poor I
couldn't afford really but you wanted to
but I wanted to you were okay and then
now with the opportunity to go to the
cons and when people when I don't go to
a certain con people will let me know on
socials like why didn't you go that's oh
that's the only person because that's
how far you know some cons are like
Regional so that's as far as someone can
drive that's as far as they're you know
allowed to can afford to travel right so
they can only travel one state over or
whatever so it feels it breaks my heart
when I hear stories of people who can't
kind of send you a Comic Con so far away
or they can only go to the Comic-Con in
Ohio and it's like I drove eight hours
to go to the complex go to that con so I
try to make as many cons as I can just
yeah my schedule allows it it's usually
in the weekends and so I don't have a
lot of weekends off but like when I can
I'll try to go to them who would you
have wanted to see if you had money if
your family had money to go to a San
Diego Comic-Con or a Comic-Con What
actors would you be like oh I gotta meet
them I gotta get a picture with them I
mean like the first one was like this
first Spider-Man you know so it was like
Toby you know like you're a big Toby
Maguire well I was at the time yeah he's
great like I'm just at that time I was
so like oh my gosh you know Spider-Man
and it came out of my birthday uh and
Rosa yeah and I was in school and I gave
her my birthday and uh May 3rd was the
premiere of the of the movie and I was
like oh my gosh on my birthday so it was
a big Spider-Man fan how old were you oh
I gotta remember I mean clear by the way
what year was this this was what year
did the first one come out
2002. so that was 20 years ago so you
were 11. it was a baby I was a baby and
the fact that I wanted to meet them so
bad because well it was you know when
you look at screen and you look at
movies and you're like it's so
aspirational like wow Hollywood glamor
it's you know movie stars uh but then
again like you know you never know where
life is gonna take you because now it's
like now that I get to go to the cons I
don't want to be that actor who didn't
go to that one con and made someone's
like dreams and Country you know what I
mean what about when you go to the cons
now are there other actors there that
you're like oh my gosh so-and-so's there
yeah I mean the first time I met William
Shatner was at a con and that was really
funny was he nice uh he was really nice
he's really like I mean guys 90 or 91
years old or something yeah 91 and he's
still going to those concerts
in Raleigh yeah and I was like wow so I
got to give it to him he's like I mean
at 91 you know why do you think he wants
to keep doing that in 91. I don't know
to keep going maybe to maybe I don't
think I don't know I can't speak for him
but like I don't know if I don't think
he needs like any kind of no more money
money or recognition and like it's like
he's his legacy is established I think
it's more maybe I would hope that it is
I think for me it would be to connect
with the fans like to be like there must
be someone out there who hasn't told him
how he they changed their life how they
made them feel how they were part of
their childhood so it must be somebody
you really think that's it I don't know
about Bill Shatner look I had a great
conversation with him one weekend and he
was really sweet maybe it's money for
his uh family to give them after that's
true you know make us I know Stan um
um Stanley Lee Stan Lee Yes
Stan I was thinking Stan Winston for a
second but Stan Lee did the same thing
he would do cons up till the very end
and I kept thinking why why but maybe he
liked it he loved the the fans he loved
they helped him create his world yeah
and he did it for them and so there's
this this symbiotic sort of relationship
I don't know yeah I think so I would
hope that it's that maybe it is money
maybe it's money that you know people
have bills to pay and family support
yeah but uh I met him through Khan what
was another one I just met the original
Red Power Ranger were you excited about
that oh yeah because I mean again that's
like my childhood you know what I mean
yeah I didn't I didn't watch the Power
Rangers when I was a kid you know wow it
was all coming together like it was and
then also the fact that some of these
you know actors and and celebrities and
whatnot were coming up to me and saying
like oh my gosh I love your show and I
was like
Isn't that cool Isn't that cool and
there's fellow peers yeah come up to you
and they're like You're great and I saw
you by the way at Easter Sunday Joe
Coy's new movie at the premiere I was
like Joe's asking me to post stuff and I
didn't get an invite to the premiere but
he wanted me to post [ __ ] [ __ ] you Joe
Coy I have a stepmom that's Filipino
he's wonderful I just met him I love him
not so long ago and uh it's so great
what he's doing obviously with the movie
and for the Filipino community and uh
it's first of its kind you know so I
definitely have to support and and it's
like one feather on one of our hats is a
feather in all our hats you know
especially being PLC yeah yeah that's
awesome yeah so look you've done a lot
of stuff I mean I'm looking at your
resume it's not like you've done
thousands of things you're still
building your career what we do in the
shadows was the biggest thing you've
done right it was like I had done a
bunch of stuff and then also in
Smallville and that was the biggest
thing I had done
um well first of all let's go back back
in time where Europe were you were you
raised by were your mom and dad together
yeah so my mom was me and my mom for the
first six years of my life so she was a
single mom working like 3 three jobs
just keeping the roof of our heads and
then when I was six she met my stepdad
and my stepdad was the most wonderful
dad like I call him my dad don't call my
stepdad because he raised me you know so
he's still with us no he passed away
like five years ago oh how hard was that
that was tough because he was such he
was the first person to encourage me to
do acting and my mom was very
traditional was wonderful in the
traditional Mexican mother sense where
she's like you have to be at you know
abogado or like a lawyer or a doctor and
I was like why are those always a two
professionals like it was like why are
the hardest professions the ones that
you choose you got to choose it's I
think that she wants you know she
sacrificed a lot to you know come to
this country and and for her Offspring
to choose and I would be an actor and
it's like well you know yeah yeah it's
not the most stable because it isn't
this if you feel a responsibility almost
to her to to pursue those things no not
in a way because I've always been
stubborn and I was always like when she
would tell me like you know she never
said I couldn't do it she just
discouraged me to do it she said because
when I fell in love with acting was I
saw Annie for the first time yeah I read
that yeah yeah and I was watching this I
thought it was a movie or a TV show I
didn't know it was a movie so we didn't
go to the movie theaters that was rich
people did that like it was a movie wow
so you were really poor we were really
bored yeah and I was like I thought this
was a new TV show during my Christmas
break so I couldn't understand what the
episodes were so back like and they're
just cohesive yeah they're like wow this
is really well edited
the commercial breaks are seamless like
there's a commercial break and it comes
back where I picked up I was like this
is good that's good writing it's really
good [ __ ] writing and um I told my
mom I fell in love with it because these
kids were poor dancing and singing and I
was like oh my gosh mom I want to be
that when I grow up I want to be an
orphan
hahaha
and she looked at me weird that's local
and she's like crazy I was like well why
don't be an orphan and she was like no
sonaktores are actors
and so you met it I want to be an actor
and literally I was just like so I told
her well how do I become an actor and
she said that's for rich kids and I was
like you gotta be rich to play poor on
television that makes no sense and then
she goes no I mean they take acting
classes dancing and voice and all that
and we don't have money for that and I
was like so I was kind of scourged then
but she saw it in my face and she said I
didn't see you couldn't do it I said
that we can't pay for that but if you
find your way Miko you can do whatever
you want you can do whatever you want
what's that mean if you find your own
way my son like my son oh it's like a
nice Swift San Antonio like sun like sun
um you can do whatever you want and I
said okay fine because I'm six years old
and I know what to do with my life uh
and we were walking home from school one
day and I found out that at the local
community center they're doing like an
improv class and it was like 12.50 how
old are you this is six you're like six
years old and this my fellow thespian at
school because we would reenact the
Disney Channel thing with the wand right
hi I'm harvesting you're watching Disney
Channel and mines would never look good
like I think you can edit this and maybe
it gets whatever I'm drawing because it
does not look like anything uh so we
were practicing we want we thought we
got on Disney Channel you could be an
actor so that was our ticket in so we're
like we're gonna be on Disney Channel we
just have to take acting classes and
then she found out there was an acting
class at a local community center it was
50 cents for improv class so two dollars
and fifty cents twelve dollars twelve
dollars and I was just like I went to my
mom and I was like can I have the money
she's like no because we have money for
that and I was like she went to her
parents and they gave her 20. and I was
like so it started teaching me like the
gap of like you know uh generational
wealth where it was like my mom was
struggling just to keep us you know
alive and how lucky was that my friend
could go to her parents you know who uh
were already paid off with their
mortgage already you know what I mean or
like whatever uh had a well education uh
degree job what not and so I was like I
don't understand the difference here and
so so I was like I had to find other way
I have to get that money and so we're
walking home from school one day and
walked by a park and this homeless man
was going through the trash can and I
was like Mom that's so gross why is he
doing that and so oh about this which
means he sells the cans right and I was
like you make money off of trash and so
I went into her closet got a wire hanger
unhooked into a long finger got a food
for less plastic bag and collected
bottles and cans
I'm gonna type it for my first improv
class
wow yeah
now a word from our sponsor betterhelp
better help I don't know what we do with
that better help uh you know I have been
lately dealing with a lot of anxiety and
what happens is I hyper focus on all
these negative things Ryan that keep
spiraling and I can't I can't it's hard
to focus it's and it exhausts me and
gives me anxiety
and these thoughts kind of just and I
know it's not I shouldn't be thinking
all these things and it's it's in my
mind I can't put it to rest a lot of
times
and um
you know it could be tough to to train
your brain to stay in problem solving
mode and you know especially when you're
facing challenges in life and I know
that therapy helps that talking to
someone and having them talk to you
objectively about what works trained
professionals helps it just does I doing
it on my own isn't working it's just not
working
if I don't have someone to talk to I
will just continue to spiral there's no
way out that's how I feel
do you feel that way yeah
um you have to talk to somebody you know
people always say well how did you get
into therapy it's because I just
couldn't solve these problems on my own
I couldn't you know it's you could say
you're gonna do these things and you're
saying oh you what happens is you just
bottle stuff up folks we just bottle
things up until it becomes very toxic
and our body feels it physiologically we
feel the effects of you know pain
depression anxiety and it takes a toll
on your mind and your body and that is
why I got into therapy and I'll tell you
A lot of times I have nothing to talk
about and for the first five minutes
like why am I here what am I doing and
by the end of it I'm like
thank God I'm talking to somebody my
Lord look if you're thinking of giving
therapy a try better help is a great
option Ryan here does better help it's
convenient accessible affordable and
entirely online get matched with a
therapist after filling out a brief
survey and switch therapists any time
um you know a lot of times people are
selling things and there's ads you have
to read to me this is the easiest read
ever because it's just something I could
talk about forever and
um look better help is is a great place
it's a it's a place to to help a lot of
people when you want to be a better
Problem Solver therapy can get you there
visit betterhelp.com inside today to get
10 off your first month that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash inside inside of you
is brought to you by Shopify if you want
your business to grow if you want to
sell stuff and you want it to be easy
and not a hassle it's Shopify period I'm
talking from experience folks I'm
talking from experience Shopify makes it
simple to sell to anyone from anywhere
whether it's it's vintage tees or
recipes for ghee starting start to start
selling with Shopify and join the
platform simplifying Commerce for
millions of your your favorite
businesses worldwide I started selling
products on the inside of you Shopify
account and at first it was just a
T-shirt and it's grown exponentially I
mean it really has grown I've got so
many items and what's great is you can
keep track of your best selling items
your lease selling items you could do
discounts it's easy to set things up I
can do this if I can do this you can do
this I have no patience okay a lot of
80d here folks Shopify makes your life
simple it's so easy and it's fun with
Shopify you'll create an online store in
your Vibe discover new customers and
grow the following that keeps them
coming back and thanks to 24 7 support
and free libraries full of educational
content shopify's got you every step of
the way it's how every minute new
sellers around the world make their
first sale with Shopify and you will too
when you're ready to launch your thing
into the spotlight do it with Shopify
the Commerce platform backing million
millions of businesses down the street
and around the globe go on try Shopify
for free and start selling everywhere
this is possibility powered by Shopify
sign up for a free trial at shopify.com
inside all lowercase go to shopify.com
inside to start selling online today
shopify.com inside
I mean that's a lot of bottles uh you're
telling me I went after two weeks and I
thought I had plenty of bottles because
I hadn't worked out the system about
squishing the aluminum can so I leave it
in whole like its whole entirely into
the bag hadn't caught up yet I know this
I know the skills of collecting cans so
I collected so many bags and I thought
the bags themselves would be money you
know gold gold in them Hills and I went
to the food for less and behind the
alley gave all of these bags all these
bags in the first round was like five
dollars and forty cents or something
like that and I was like No And it took
me two weeks to earn these so I went
back to the parks I crashed quinceaner
us I poured out to have them drink beer
bottles and people got mad at me and ran
and like totally like hijacked because I
needed to pay for this and finally got
the money I took the class the class was
like an hour and a half it was
babysitting because it divided us from
six to like nine-year-olds right and
then like 10 to like probably 14 or 15.
the older kids got like actual
assignments like they were like okay
guys improv but like let's make it fun
and blah blah and the little kids were
just walking around all together in a
group and they were just like now you're
lying okay now you're a tiger now you're
a bear like all kinds of animals and
you're just acting it out and for some
reason whatever I was doing was making
everyone laugh and I was just like
there's this crackle to like performing
that I never felt before and I still
feel it to this day but it was that was
the first day I felt it like I was like
whoa people are having fun and I'm
making them laugh and I I can give them
a good experience and so entertaining
was like what I knew I wanted to do from
that day right from the first improv
class you took you could tell the
reception of what you were doing was
something fun something good you felt
good doing it and you went back home to
your mother and you said Mom yeah I want
to do this again I want to be an orphan
and more bottles more bottles yeah I
kept doing it and it's so funny because
whenever someone says like recently with
shadows they're like oh my God what an
overnight success you know and I was
like for me it's been a journey you know
so no one sees the the ups and downs or
the collecting cans in your six and I
did that for a while and after a while I
had to get smart to making money quicker
and so I remember when I was little I
was like seven or eight I would help my
stepdad at that point my mom had
remarried and got my stepdad and I would
help with this construction company so
in my Summers I go and like just haul
like bricks over to where they were
working at seven years old seven seven
and eight yeah and like it wasn't like
you know huge manual labor he wouldn't
let me do like the big stuff it was just
like move that you know three blocks or
three bricks or whatever over there
which is home how much would he pay you
he paid me like at the end of the day I
was paying like 20 bucks or something
like that which was enough for a class
that's pretty good and one day one day
in the summer to get 20 bucks at the end
of the day it's pretty good and so and
he knew that's what it was feeding like
he knew that like he was kind of you
know financing that like passion of mine
because eventually I heard that there
was like a
robber power or whatever at the mall
kind of thing scenario where they're
like you want to be on Disney Channel
then come on down to the mall and sign
up for Robert power it was like you know
uh and I don't know it was specifically
that so if you're listening to Robert
Powers don't come out at me but it was
one of those things where it was like
come to the mall and if you want to be
an actor we're looking for young actors
and it was a scam it was like they
charge you 500 for headshots and that's
what you got to get done all you never
went past that like you just charge and
they gave you your headshots and like
here you go but the headshots cost like
50 bucks to take and they pocket 450.
and they disappear they disappear but I
never did the program because my I want
to do it so bad my mom was like no no no
something's wrong with like it sounds
weird no Mom if you just pay for it they
just they put you on Disney I was so
convinced and that's how they get their
clientele they get the kids to get
excited and get their parents and then
my mom said no but my dad saw how
heartbroken I was he was like
I guess I'll wait in the car I'll take
you in a bit and so he like stalled and
like I went in the car he took me to the
thing and after listening to this lady
selling me on this I knew it was a scam
as a child like I was only like eight
and I was like and I was like okay but
when do we start filming like I was like
asking questions and she was like well
you don't start filming hon until you
get your picture so if your dad just
gives us 500 right now and I was like no
I literally told my dad really yeah I
was like No And I was like so I have to
take pictures like but just pictures
alone are gonna cost 100 and she was
like why don't you let your dad pay for
that and I was like I was always good at
picking up like people's I don't know
like I could tell if you're a good
person or a bad person off the bat their
energy their energy I'm really big on
energy yeah to this day I go off energy
a lot so something felt wrong and my Dad
loved him so much like he was about to
pay a 500 and I was like No And I
stopped my dad from paying because I
knew I would never forgive myself if he
paid 100 for this scam which I knew it
was a scam already wow so he walked out
of there and I was like Dad I was like
no I was like no no it's a bit of that
like it's hot real and he's oh okay
because my dad was just gonna pay for
whatever I want you know what I mean and
it was really sweet and like I remember
that day I was like oh my gosh she
believes in me like he wants me to do
this and it was like the encouragement
which cut to you know doing a movie in
Canada was my first time in Canada he
felt ill because how old were you this
was not the longest one like five years
ago oh wow and uh I was doing a film
there and my dad fell ill because he'd
been smoker his whole life and he was in
the hospital but my mom didn't tell me
because he didn't want to bother me at
work and so he'd been in the hospital
for like a month and so I would call and
like say how you doing he like pretended
he was okay and then I got back uh home
and literally it was heartbreaking
before I got there my mom's like just
let you know he's been in the hospital I
was like Mom why don't you tell me he's
like because he didn't want you to fly
back home and worry about it and I was
like okay that's ridiculous I would have
left that movie it was like stupid you
know what I mean and I just like got
back and went to the hospital it was
like July I think second and I saw him
in the hospital I was like oh yeah they
put me all this stuff it's fine I'm
gonna be fine I was like okay Dad and I
was like okay we'll see you tomorrow I
was like okay and then he passed away
that night and I was just like he waited
till I got home
to say goodbye and I was like and he was
he was the best dad and so I miss him
terribly but he totally believed in me
so I hope he's really proud of the work
that I've done isn't that isn't that
most of it when someone that you love
and look up to
um
supports you and what you want to do
yeah and gives you unconditional love
and says if that's what you want I mean
there's nothing better no it really does
make a huge difference you know it does
I get it with the parents you know who
have to be cautious and want to give
them like a realistic but it doesn't
hurt to kind of like you know always
encourage whatever that dream is because
you'd rather be happy doing what you
love or at least try to do what you love
and if you don't succeed at least you
tried you know you could always say I
tried it and it wasn't for me I tried it
it was hard especially in this business
this business has so many you know Peaks
and and valleys that it's like it's hard
to encourage anyone to get into this
business because it really is I always
tell people no yeah stay away if you can
find anything else anything else you
love just as much do that anything else
with stability but because you love
doing this so much and we wouldn't be
doing it if we didn't love it so much
you know and be willing to put up with
those valleys because the Peaks are so
great how has your mom done without your
father she's just she you know it's
tough for a bit obviously
um but she's done okay and we have her
whole family that live uh next door to
her so she always has support and my
nieces and my brothers and my sister are
nearby all the time uh in fact I want to
see her tomorrow but yeah it's so weird
to think because now looking at her look
at the result of me wanting to be an
actor the Highlight for her was when I
was the spokesperson at Metro PCS in
Spanish
and this was like my early my career she
would tell everyone about those
commercials like she I come over and
she'll be having like coffee with like
the neighbors and she's like
that's my son
from MetroPCS and I was like wow that's
okay you have to announce it every time
I come home he's like it's Nicole
PCS you know she loved it she loved it
because I was in Spanish she understood
it and it was like commercials are a
huge thing in the Spanish market so to
be in a commercial that repeats itself
every commercial break and you're on
everyone's screen I would go to
restaurants in La and like be hanging
out with like you know uh somewhere in
the back and like the the chef or like
the runners would be like hey you know
what I mean like and they'd be like oh
my God you're watching like you would be
famous and Spanish speaking environment
because of the commercial and then you
step out into an English-speaking
environment no one who you were like you
walk out and you'd be like okay see you
guys later like the MetroPCS and then
someone would be like excuse me sir you
know it's like are you the valet and I
was like what no no what no it's just
like so it's it's funny to see that
because for my mom I've hit the Pinnacle
of like success with MetroPCS nothing
will ever top that like she constantly
reminds me she'll like oh still to this
day to this day she asked me if I'm
doing more commercials in MetroPCS and I
was like Mom I'm gonna hit show blah
blah Metro PCS
and I was like no no more MetroPCS
okay
like so like I can see the
disappointment on her face through you
yes it's literally every time I see her
like I I've like you know gone Accolade
and won you know Awards and stuff like
Mom I want a glider War which is like
you know great blah blah oh okay Bueno
pero MetroPCS
Society was brought to you by Freedom
grooming I was bald for seven years
where was this product when I was bald I
constantly nicked myself with razors the
makeup artist on Smallville would Nick
my head I'd bleed I'd get razor bumps
but none of this would happen if I had
freedom grooming Freedom grooming we
make the flex series electric shaver
this thing is awesome it's uniquely
designed to flex and Contour to the
curve of your head for a smoother faster
and safer shave without the risk of
Nicks Cuts irritation or ingrowns uh
it's pretty incredible and they work
anywhere on the body
it's pretty awesome because I'm kind of
a hairy guy so I could take care of my
chest some of my back
my head if I want my face
Freedom grooming they really do it
they've really done it with this great
product
um I have friends that I've given the
product to my friend Joe
and uh he loves it I think this is
something that everybody should have uh
it's the old days are over folks the old
days of nicking and all this irritation
all this crap we've technologically
grown and so has Freedom grooming with
their amazing Flex series electric
shaver get the smoothest shave of your
life flexible blades Contour to the
shape of your head for a baby smooth
shave every time shave 50 percent more
hair in a single stroke compared to
traditional razors expect shave time two
three minutes tops not 10 or 15. never
cut yourself shaving again the flex
series Safeguard technology means no
Nicks no ingrown hairs and no problems
and the flex series waterproof design
means you can shave in the shower
without or with shaving cream shave wet
or shave dry
pretty amazing we have over ten thousand
five star reviews uh and with a close
shave plan you'll never run out of fresh
sharp blades delivered to your door
every six weeks with free shipping it's
the closed shave plan and members are
upgraded to a lifetime warranty yeah
it's completely customizable just skip
or cancel your plan anytime Ryan and to
thank you for being such a loyal
listener we're partnering with freedom
to give you an exclusive 20 off when you
go to freedomgrooming.com slash inside
that's
freedomgrooming.com slash inside inside
you is brought to you by Geico Geico
asks how would you love a chance to save
some money on insurance well of course
you would after all who doesn't love a
great deal right and when it comes to
Great rates on insurance for all the
things in your life Geico can help like
with insurance for your car truck
motorcycle boat and RV even help with
homeowners condo or renters coverage you
could save even more with a special
discount when you bundle your coverages
plus add the easy to use Geico mobile
app available 24-hour roadside
assistance and more and choosing to
switch to Geico becomes an Easy Choice
switch today and see all the ways you
could save with great rates and
discounts it's easy simply go to
geico.com to get a rate quote or contact
your local agent and get started seeing
how much you could save
did you um do you remember when you came
out to your mother yes I came out when
she kept insisting that my friend was my
best friend to this day
um Adriana was so pretty she was like
she's really pretty she is really pretty
yeah uh unbeknownst to my mother Adriana
is queer lesbian and I was like yeah
she's really beautiful and she's like
she has no boyfriend I was like no I
don't think so I don't think she's no no
she doesn't and it's not my place to
tell us and how old were you at this
point it was high school high school
this High School this is like sophomore
in high school Maybe Junior and my mom
always knew but she never officially had
an answer or a a sentence or a quote for
me to to validate what her hunts or her
you know yeah uh and so it was weird
because I knew she knew how did you know
she knew I think her mother always knows
you know like I think it's just like and
I think me seeing show tunes uh you know
at our Gatherings that's true and I
don't want like you know categorize you
know people who thinks but like I think
I was always free in my being that like
I thought she knew because I was always
accused of it by others was that hard it
was hard because she always would have
to put up with that like you know one of
my my
um traumatic memories of knowing that I
was different and knowing that it was
because I was queer was because I was in
Mexico with my Tonka truck which I like
playing with Tonka trucks very manly
very boy yeah but also had dolls and so
yeah dolls and you had Tonka trucks and
then people are like what's going on
here you know and it's just like playing
on my Tonka track oh so play with my
doll you know I'm just like
um boys don't play with like I remember
having a conversation with like the
local kids where my grandma's like you
know Ranch thing was and it was like
they could tell
that I was just myself and for some
reason that was threatening and it was
weird because it was different and I
just always loved playing and make
believe and so I remember like I was
trying to play trucks with these boys
and they're like we can't play trucks
with you because my brother says you're
a Mariposa what's that mean my brother
says you're a butterfly which is a
derogatory way of saying you're you're
gay
um
and that I'd understand it and I was
like Mariposa I was like they're
beautiful what's wrong with them I
didn't know what the negative
connotation to Mariposa was at that age
right because it's pretty young and so
they were saying it over and over and I
was like what do you what like I and
then I knew it was bad I knew it was bad
because I felt it and I felt that it
felt bad to be this because you don't
like it and you don't like me being this
and it was like they kept chanting it
and I was like why do I play with you
anyways and I grabbed my Tonka truck and
I walked away and they kept chanting it
over and this and then I felt something
fly to the side of my ear and then I
turned around and just like rocks flying
towards me and one of them hit me right
here where I have the scar and I just
remember like gash my face and just
blood gushing over my face and I just
remember crying and running with my
truck and I dropped my truck and they
kept chanting the word and I was just
covered in jerks I found the dirt now
it's dirt and mud on my face Lord like
became like mud with the blood in the
sand and they're just like dirt all over
writing to my mom
screaming I was like
okay
and my mom just looked at me and then
she said
like who cares that they called you
butterfly butterflies are beautiful
and I just remember thinking it was okay
but I know she was making me feel better
and she was making me feel better about
what I was so I knew she knew at that
moment either that age because she would
always protecting me from people like
that because I grew up in a very
machismo you know environment and
culture
um unfortunately our culture is very
much useful you know and it was uh it
was heartbreaking because I knew that
she was fighting the fight for me but it
was like I think that moment when I came
out it was more to tell her officially
like she kept hinting it she just wanted
me to say it and she basically said I
was like yeah it's really pretty nothing
to know
maybe you can be her boyfriend I was
like Mom you know I'm queer right and
she goes
I don't care as long as you're happy she
just wanted to hear it she just wanted
to hear it I think for her sake so we
can actually put that to rest but I
think it was it went without saying
because for so many years she kind of
protected me from you know what I mean
right so I think it was more for like
let's just close that chapter we know it
and we said it it's done as opposed to
like Teeter because I would bring so
many girls home and they're all your
friends yeah and she would always be I
think I think at some point she got
confused she was like or she had
confused that I could be bi it could you
know what I mean like it was just like
so you know when I told her I was like
yeah I was like I bring girls home right
like it wasn't like I was bringing them
home to like you know take them in my
room and like do stuff it was just like
I think she couldn't understand like she
was like what what's going on or I go on
weekend trips you know and some would be
with like girls and some of the guy and
she's like what's going on you know it's
like what's going on here so I think it
was more to like a safety thing too you
know has she met any of your boyfriends
yeah she has she's mad uh all of them
actually yeah she's not all of them was
there one in particular if she really
liked and she was sad to see go yes
there was
um it was one that was particularly hard
for her because they were very nice I
don't even want to mention the name
because then I don't want to put them on
the spotlight right but it was someone
who was like very lovely right and then
those others that she did not care for
and she made it very cool and she was
she right in the long run I think she
was right yeah she was right all along
like instincts were right Lindsay's from
good and bad right her instance were
good uh things didn't work out with the
one that she liked but that was more
personal thing for me you know just like
I just don't feel it and you know and
it's just like can't you make it feel it
I'm just like I just don't you know um
but yeah she's met all of them do you
think you'd like to get married someday
I don't know uh I think I like the idea
me too I I don't know yeah I don't know
and people are always like well there
you know you could always get married I
was like I don't I feel like being in a
relationship is hard enough that
sometimes adding this I don't know the
strain of like a wedding and like
um a lot of religions fall apart I think
during a wedding uh or the process of a
wedding you know because it really shows
you the stress and if you can work under
stress and I already got enough stress
uh right now like I don't need any more
stress do you have a lot of stress well
I feel like with my schedule I don't
have a lot of time to have time with a
partner that was kind of the reason why
the other relationship that or my
password should dissolved was because I
shoot out of the country and I can't be
home what do you shoot in Toronto in
Toronto so the reason my last
relationship fell apart was because
um that person wanted someone home at
five and felt heartbroken that we didn't
have as much time you know and it's not
fair to that person so literally I was
the one
kind of cut it off and was like then you
should be with someone who's home at
five for dinner and say well I want to
be with you and it's like but if you
want to be with me then you understand
that I can't be home you know right so
see how that doesn't work and it's like
well we'll make it well I'll give her
another go it's like it doesn't sound
like because this is the conversation we
had earlier it was like I work a lot I
travel a lot unfortunately so when I am
with someone I'm 150 in it like I am
romantic I try to make efforts to like
take you know weekend getaways take
vacations to spend time together you
need someone who understands understand
has their own thing going going on you
can do your own thing and there's no
questioning it there's no making you
feel guilty yes there's no stress yes
that's exactly what we need in our lives
we need somebody to say go [ __ ] off I'll
[ __ ] off yeah and we'll [ __ ] off
together yeah is that too much to ask
it's not too much to ask because people
don't get that people are like well I
just like so I like my partner to be
like by my side although I don't I want
you to have your own fear yeah I want
you to go do and I want you to tell me
about it when I see you the next time I
see you
and also something about distance makes
you long somewhere you know what I mean
like if it's like every second of every
day it's just a lot you know what I mean
and I've always said this and I was
talking to my friend Nicole about this
and she was saying I want my own room
when I'm with someone and I need a house
with my own room our room that we're
together and your room yeah you know
what I mean and when we're together
that's our room when I come home after
whatever day I've had if I need to
decompress and like let's say I was
doing an emotional scene and just it
always reminds me of that episode of Sex
in the City when Carrie Bradshaw comes
in and she's telling I think it's Burger
she's doing at the time but she says can
you shut up for five minutes
because you walk in and he starts
talking he's like hey babe how was your
day which is really positive right
really yeah but yeah for five minutes
because that's what you need sometimes I
like to come home I think we'll be
globers at this like I don't want anyone
in my home like I don't want I don't
want anyone in my house like I just want
to go home and sometimes like I've
because what we do is we we deal with
people every day so we interact with
people we have to act with people we are
social with people at parties that's
part of our job you know we go and do
that so when you go home sometimes I
don't want anyone there you literally
just want to watch like reality TV I
broke up right before the pandemic yeah
which was the perfect time I think
people are like oh no quarantine Harvey
how you doing your own by so I love it
like I literally was like I'm loving it
yes you know after a while we get lonely
and afterwards you have to FaceTime you
know your family and whatnot but
I actually enjoyed it a little bit
because it was like a pause button for a
second and it was like this is good this
is good for me for me it was good I
can't speak for everyone but for me it
was good I was like at least the first
couple months then after a while you're
like okay let's you know get the ball
rolling again right but yeah I just uh
you need to find someone who's
compatible with you that way where like
they understand they have their own [ __ ]
going on go away come back but that's
hard to find or something that's hard to
date another actor and so I stopped
dating actors because especially if
you're dating another male actor or I
was dating someone who was an actor but
most more of a model than anything and
shallow and also that came yes but also
that came with its own kind of thing
where like people would make me feel
honored that I was with this person like
people would be like I was like oh this
is my partner and we're like oh Harvey
good job and I was like how about good
job him yeah like good job him I'm
awesome and beautiful and yeah what is
it the butterfly what is it the cuckoo
oh yeah beautiful
uh but it was so weird and I was very
telling of your friends of who like
valued you know and yes this this person
was very good looking you know and like
whatever I'm pretty sure I saw pictures
of him probably
he who should not be named but it's just
the idea that that we put so much value
on that you know because you didn't know
what was going on behind closed doors
you know there was a horrible partner
you know what I mean that there were uh
yeah all the stuff that could be set
that could you know right could be the
opposite of that is not said because you
are also trying to keep this
relationship uh afloat because now
people have approved it or they want you
to be in this relationship like don't
miss this one and it's like don't why
would I be the one you know it's like
why uh so that was right here I've heard
that too where it's like you know we
really liked so and so she was a good
one what do you do you messed that one
why why does it mean well is it you know
I was like well she had some dark ass
secrets she was like you did you guys
didn't know her like I'm just saying we
really liked her package for you yeah
I'm like good God would you shut up the
packaging looks great right yeah and
then even then people people come for
you
um it came with its own like you know
things like where why are they together
you know it's just like the the body
shaming or like the hot this doesn't
make sense by Society standards you know
and it's like well then you know what
then take your Society standards and
shove it up here you know it's just like
the idea I so but that's why I've
changed from being open to maybe dating
actors and sometimes you know you'll go
on a date but since my time is kind of
limited right now I haven't been
pursuing that happening right right but
um but I'm open to like you know the
last person I did was an engineer you
know so I was like different and just
like different where you're like okay we
can have a question mix it up and
nothing to do with the industry you're
still young so you don't need to jump in
anything yeah you need to take care of
you yeah your career is taking off yeah
you've got things going on what we do in
the shadows yeah which by the way I
first of all I love the movie
um taiki
the mother God Tyco ITT right I saw the
movie and I fell in love with it I
couldn't get the song out of my head
Ryan loves the show I love the show I
don't watch many shows and this is one
that I watch I haven't started the
fourth season yeah catch up uh I'm going
to catch up but what what I'm current on
it you're correct oh yeah oh tonight's
new episode yeah
but it's what an exciting
show to be on
and you were you uncertain that they
were going to pick it up because they
waited a while didn't they well I didn't
know if we were gonna well first of all
I didn't I was gonna get the roll
because Guillermo was ran 20 years older
than I am and so I I got the audition by
by accident I went to a wine and cheese
night
you went to wine and cheese now and
she's neither my friend Mimi Michaels
was having that's not that's on her
stage and that's her name meaning
Michaels maybe Michael
um we met in a commercial set years and
years ago became friends and she just
had a newborn and she had brought the
baby to see the family here on the West
Coast her brother uh it was her her
husband the baby her at her brother's
house and she was like just come by say
hi I won't see you for you know who
knows because I'm gonna go back to the
east coast and I haven't been able to
get back there at that point
so I said okay so I went to the wine
cheese night I met this girl who was
there her name is Yvonne her friend uh
from before that I never met before and
we didn't talk about the Hollywood or
business or anything we're just having
like a good old time and the next day I
get a text from an unknown number and I
was like hey you were so [ __ ] funny
last night I was like thanks
who's this enjoy it's Yvonne and I was
like oh Yvonne from last night I got
your number from Mimi's uh I hope that's
okay and I was like yeah that's fine and
I think you should audition for my
fiance's new show and I was like your
fiance's new show yeah it was your
fiance yeah exactly I was like okay I
don't do those kind of films and it was
just like no but you should hurry
because her cat they've cast everyone in
this show except for this role and I was
like okay so I call my agent and tell
her her fiance is Garrett bash at the
time who produces the show and I told my
age I was like I gotta get in for this
show and they're like okay we'll get you
the script and they're like oh wait the
characters are you sure that's the
character I was like yeah it's 20 years
older than you are and I was like oh she
said I'd be fine for it so I'm gonna
believe a stranger you know go with that
and they're like I'm gonna whim and I
was like well maybe I shouldn't go in
for it and they're like and I said who's
casting it and it's like Allison Jones I
was like I was like Allison Jones if you
know Allison Jones in Hollywood I was
like she's got everything that I've
always loved you know bridesmaids the
office Fresh Prince Golden Girl Like You
Name It you know what I mean and I was
just like I want to go meet her I've
never met her so I was like okay this is
my chance I'll just meet her I'll just
make myself look older so I got this
long sleeve orange shirt and brown
sweater vest and Harry Potter glasses
and I don't know a lot of guillermos and
the one that I knew at that time wasn't
a poster and my writing partner's office
and it was Guillermo del Toro and it was
from his Monster's book and he had his
hair curled to the sides like this and
he had round glasses and I was like I
was like I'll mimic that so I mimic my
look off of how long did you have to
learn your lines there was like the the
complimentary audition as I call it uh
they called that day and the audition
was the next day did you learn all your
lines I learned everything I went home
and like went over it and I was like oh
[ __ ] he is older and I was like okay I
want to go play it at my age I'll play
him at my age now fine that's fine so I
was really looking forward to meet
Allison going to the office and we're
like I'm here to meet Allison Jones like
oh she's not here I was like well no I
have an audition for her no we'll put
you on tape she's in London audition for
Guillermo's
okay so I was like great and then they
put a microphone on me and I've been the
casting associate who's wonderful too
and he was like okay and then I remember
doing it and I was looking up and then
he's a harvey now yeah
and he goes you're done
and I was like oh I think I just
completely went away like I don't
remember what I did for the audition and
I was like oh thank you you were so into
it I was so into it that you forgot what
you had done you didn't know if you'd
done well nothing you've done poorly
nope
so I walk out I'm walking out the door
and he goes Harvey wait and I go I think
he's in a year ago in a Hollywood kid
you know you should go to the next level
he goes to the microphone
we need the microphone and he took the
microphone off of me and I was like oh
shoot I I think I messed it up and then
I went outside and my agent calls her
how'd you do and I was like I don't know
and I was like well we'll check in we'll
see two hours later they called back and
they had shown everyone at FX taika
Jermaine Paul Stephanie like her fiance
uh Garrett had seen it Allison at scene
in London and they all agreed to test me
unanimously they were like it was the
first time they voted to test someone
unanimously at the first for the whole
run and that was gonna be the wild card
because I was too young and I was like
[ __ ] I was like okay it's fine I'll get
to meet them eventually you know I'll do
the the test and whatnot so weeks went
by were you nervous yeah I was nervous I
was like this is a test and I've always
my career is made out of wild cards like
if you look at my resume those roles
were never written for me some of the
rules you see on like IMDb that's right
candy eye candy they the original
Creator uh wanted to fire me because he
thought I was too big and not uh MTV uh
handsome material
so after the pilot he fought to like get
rid of me and then the fans were like we
love that character and they're like no
okay keep him keep him but I found out
this afterwards what about magicians
magicians was not for me they told me
that um I couldn't set my tape in
because it had options in LA but I was
shooting in Vancouver and they shoot in
Vancouver so I was sneaky and got an
audition through the Vancouver office so
as long as I got on tape and the
producers saw me they liked it and they
liked it and they told the casting
office in La we found this guy in
Vancouver who Harvey and they're like
but we told him no
and it wasn't written for like they
wasn't meant for me like they didn't
want me to audition for it you forced
your way in I forced myself away well
they originally gave me an audition and
they took the audition away because they
said we have enough uh options tonight
don't worry about it on tape and they
didn't want to see tapes from Vancouver
because they have an office they're like
no don't worry about it we have options
and we're going to producers tomorrow
and I was like I learned the lines Why
did you tell me to put myself on tape so
part of me was stubborn I was like no
there has to be a way around I already
learned the lines you know right so I
got the audition in Vancouver they send
the taped producers The Producers told
the casting office in La we found this
guy and it was the guy that told no to
so back to what we do in the shadows
you're waiting a couple of weeks wait a
couple weeks and then it's I don't hear
anything so I think they're starting
production on that Tuesday this is a
Sunday now so it's over it's over not
doing this and with my sister she's
keeping my cheer you know trying to
cheer me up and keeping my spirits up we
go to the mall and we're walking around
because that's what we do when you're
low in the dumps
um and she my phone keeps ringing like
from a 16 digit number and I was like
whatever I'd ignore it eventually she's
in the car and she's like will you pick
up the [ __ ] phone and I was like oh
my gosh I was like hello I'm like hey is
this Hobby and I was like yeah hey it's
talking Jermaine hi uh Mr waititi yes I
I think I'm testing for you no you're
not testing for us thank you so much and
I was like thank you so much for the
opportunity I wish you all the best in
your product look I thought he was
calling me because you know something I
hold they call you like not going your
way you know they tell you that they
give you a complimentary call and say
they're going a different direction you
know right so I thought that's what they
were doing I thought they were calling
to say
thank you but we're starting this week
already but you did a great audition or
whatever so I was like thank you so much
for the opportunity I wish you all the
best I know we'll see you on set and I
was like what and it's like yeah was he
on set and it was a Sunday Monday was
Martin Luther King day and Tuesday I had
a fitting and Wednesday I was on set
that's how I booked it
we got Hollywood
uh what was your first day on set like
were you a intimidated being nervous as
[ __ ] see I mean what were the emotions
or were you confident you're ready to go
or were you just overwhelmed I was
I was looking forward to meeting
taika and Jermaine obviously because by
that point I'd seen the movie and I was
such a fan and Flight of the Conchords
and all that and yeah so I was just
excited to meet them but I was more
nervous to meet the cast because I was
gonna have to act opposite of Kayvon I
never had the chemistry read so you know
in Hollywood that can make or break a
character storyline and I I was nervous
to meet him and so I was like oh please
because the script is so good I knew the
script was good I was like if I just
make this pilot and the pie doesn't go
I'll have this footage right I'll have
this footage like I can keep this
because it's so good like I was like the
script is so good and I got to set and
the first thing came I was like hey man
and he just like gave me this huge hug
and he was so welcoming and loving I was
like thank God you know
and and and it worked out we shot the
pilot and after I shot the pilot I knew
that it was really special like I was
like we have to get picked this is crazy
like this is such a good show uh but
good shows don't tend to last long you
know like sometimes they get canned
really quickly and that had been the
trajectory up to that part I was really
part of the shows that I've done like
eye candy was a book made into a series
only did one season super expensive to
make but beautifully shot and it was
like a movie
um huge was a book by Sasha Paley made
into a series which was my first series
regular ever which had so much potential
but it was ahead of its time people
still talk about that show today they're
like oh I love that show why did it I
was like I don't know even the president
at the time of you know that was just
free form was back then was ABC Family
um even they moved forward and went to
like MTV years later and even I had a
conversation with them and they're like
I should have never canceled here and I
was like you shouldn't you shouldn't
have because it was one of those things
where it was like you pulled the trigger
too quickly and it was like damn you
never just would have waited
um it had a fan base you know so
anyways I was really hoping that I was
like this is the one that like please
make into a series and then we got
season one and I was like oh my gosh we
got a season so I had not planned
anything further than season one because
I was like they're gonna like see how
cool this is and either they're gonna
say yes or they're gonna count it and
then we got nominated you know and then
we got the nominations for Emmys we got
so it was like Season Two Season three
and before you knew it it was just like
like the last three seasons have been
the blur because it kind of happened
during the pandemic and so we shot two
seasons during the pandemic
um which is just credit to this like
crew they couldn't find like wood to
build the sets because no one was
delivering like during the pandemic
there was no shipments of like actual
like you know wood and labor like or uh
you know tools and costume pieces and uh
and fabric to make costume like they
went above and beyond to make the show
during the pandemic like our crew loves
our show so much they went above and
beyond like I applaud them because
they're the best I yeah
I read for Nando did you nandor nandor
did you review I read I went to Allison
Jones office oh my God I read for her
upstairs when you go upstairs and I read
and I it's funny because I thought I
killed it I had the ax and I had all
these things and then when I saw him uh
like the actor do it I go oh my God I
couldn't he's perfect yeah I mean it's
the casting in that overall is just
everyone is just great yeah everyone has
their own personality is there one in
particular one actor that makes you
laugh the most for some reason
it's probably a cave on most of my
scenes already came on and he plays in
Andor he's just a master of voices he
can mimic anyone on Set uh he can is he
always joking always joking
um also he'll he'll make a joke and then
he'll remember and laugh at his own joke
that he's just made so he'll be like and
then he'll be like and he starts
laughing and he knows that like I rarely
Break characters
only human and he's so contained because
the vampires get to be over the top
great character of like you know almost
like a farce you know and that's to
improvised constantly all the time like
our show is made of 50 scripted and 50
YouTube yeah yours is 50 improvised
that's why this cast I've never been
with the cast like this where everyone's
firing on all cylinders it's playing
like hot potato and the potatoes never
dropped we had us we had a season one
take that ended up being about 20
seconds in the show but we shot for
maybe 28 minutes of Improv just let the
camera roll
28 minutes of us going off script it was
like who like it was a revolving door
kind of thing where we're in the living
room and Nando's like Guillermo and I'm
like I'm in the I'm in the fancy room
Guillermo I'm over here master guillerm
and he comes into another door and I
exit the other door he's okay and then
Naja comes in so what are you yelling
about I'm looking for Guillermo I just
saw him to the other room he goes that
room like it was like
just 26 minutes for 26 minutes no one
yelled cut and you'll never see that
footage because it was only 20 seconds
of it that you need it in the beginning
was it intimidating to for them to go
keep going ah improvise go I don't for
me no because I tend to want to
improvise a lot and that you know that's
not usually the norm like in the
scripted series like you know you'll
have obviously you know you get on
certain shows and they're like this has
to be verbatim you know what I mean like
this is why like so you can't paraphrase
you can't add words I like a little bit
of like ad-lib because it makes if
you're organic it makes you feel like
these characters are real they're not
like just like I don't know what's going
to happen you know like it's not like
you know so yeah to the T that it's just
like ah
um I like improvising so for me it was
fun I you tell me to improvise improvise
all day long so the lines are written so
you have to read certain lines these are
the lines we want you to say yeah and
then do whatever you want yeah so the
we'll always do a take with a scripted
version and that's what Tycoon Germaine
what's so lovely is they set this rule
up for us even though like now they're
you know doing projects all over the
world and stuff and they'll come and say
hi once in a while but like it's now
been handed over to our amazing EPS um
you know Paul and Stephanie uh and Sarah
naftales who are amazing at continuing
that tradition where they go get one as
script written you know which is already
the scripture bites if we didn't
improvise on the show but still like
they're good they're so good that we get
the the freedom to do one scripted
version and then they go we call it
funsies so then our director Kyle new at
check our director goes all right
funsies or yeah
you know which means that we got what we
wanted we got the take scripted now have
fun and usually the episode is 50
scripted and fifty percent who has the
most lines
I would say nandor because
I I mean like well he's kind of like
he's the lead of the show and his
storyline is always revolving some kind
of Adventure and it's kind of hard to
like say but I would say him because he
has all these like monologues where he
talks about like his past life or
whatever but not looking at it because
of the past Seasons I feel like
everyone's kind of had a season where
like it's like it's like last year last
season was nausea or this season is
nausea heavy whereas she had tons of
lines to learn because she's the
nightclub she you know she's I don't
want to do spoilers but like she opens a
nightclub uh and um she's dealing with
being a boss uh money blah blah so she
has a lot this season so it's like a
nausea heavy and you guys have a lot of
time to memorize lines because they have
them all written by uh
um even though they have the funny part
of the show is that they keep the
tradition alive like the movie where
they don't tell the actors what the
storyline is and to this day like I
don't know what this next season is but
I already have friends who are actors
who have told me that they're audition
for the show
they're like oh my gosh I'm so excited
to play blank blank you're blah blah
blah what he's like yeah I'm blah blah
they're auditioning right now for this
part for season for episode 505 or
whatever wow and I'm like I don't know
what the first word of the sentence or
the first script is of the season and
you know which is kind of like a little
bit like jarring because it's like for
me for my character he's human so I
would like a little bit of preparation
you know to like familiar he's a
familiar and so the season the first
season was hard for me because at the
end of the day the Vampires will wrap
their story lines in the episode like
they were like we figure out how to work
email you know it solves itself calling
gets a promotion at work it solves
itself for the end of the episode but
Guillermo like was sprinkling throughout
the whole thing to lead to something
um a big reveal you know and I would
like to know what the reveal is so I
know what to sprinkle along the way
right so then it makes sense otherwise I
look an idiot at the end of the season
they go and surprise you're this and
you're like you're a Vampire Slayer well
I would have liked to sprinkle something
they hint you know or maybe not Hint it
but my process would have been a little
bit different you know what I mean if I
knew that if I if I didn't know that I
was a vampire then leave it alone I
don't want to know because it's organic
I don't know that I'm a Vampire Slayer
but if I knew something that came up in
the in the future for my past that would
have been nice to know you know what I
mean right so those are those moments
where you're like I wish I knew but it
does make for it to feel like a real
mockumentary you know or a documentary
it's a mockery but it keeps on your toes
if you ever do you ever feel like saying
hey taika if you need anybody in any of
your Marvel movies oh yeah we always
joke around I mean I feel like don't
worry all yeah
um what was the last time we talked and
I said something
oh yeah I was just making a joke of like
being Star Wars or something and it's
like you're not old enough and I was
like I'm not old and I'm old and put me
in like it was like you know he makes a
joke that I was like a baby of the group
and I was like I think I'm old enough I
think I can I can grow a beard I'm older
uh this is called [ __ ] talking with
Harvey Guillen this is these are my
patrons the top tier patrons they get to
ask some questions go to patreon.com
inside of you uh thank you for
supporting the show these people they're
amazing my patrons support the podcast
and they get to ask some questions right
so this is rapid fire okay so you could
just here we go you ready okay good
Raj have you ever met a Colin in real
life that drained you just from having
to interact with them yes absolutely not
I feel like not so much
we all have we all have yeah
energy vampire yeah I feel like we all I
mean not so much maybe in the industry
because the actors tend to be
entertaining and fun and wonderful and
bubbly but there is sometimes someone
who works maybe an event or something or
yeah I think I had one time
um it was someone like someone's manager
or something and it was like you're
you're a Colin
sure I don't know what his other name
but
Michelle K
saw you at the last Comic-Con in Raleigh
wondering how you like convention since
you you're new to the scene we kind of
talked about that yeah
um I like them like again I love meeting
uh the fans I think they've been you
know so supportive of the show and end
of my career in general so I love
meeting especially when a fan comes up
and says that they see themselves on
screen because you know for so long all
those check marks that were against me
like being queer plus size Latina those
are all strikes against me in this
industry when I first got started not
anymore and those are all my strengths
they've always been my strengths and
isn't that beautiful yeah and people are
finally seeing them as my strength and
someone's watching me on screen saying I
didn't see myself represented on screen
but I feel seeing when I see you and
have tears in their eyes so that word
that alone is worth going all the cons
wow that's awesome Leanne P loved your
work in reach her what was it like
working with Alan rich and as easy as
nice on the set as he is in person he's
such a professional like he's so like
that guy's schedule is crazy like he he
was working six six days a week and he
has a family and and still you know
devote it to them and and making quality
time with his kids and uh super funny
not just a serious guy but he has a
really funny side uh but that guy's like
this go go he was in the podcast and he
really got deep and talked about like
when he tried to
um uh kill himself yeah and his
depression and and it was just it was it
was good to hear from a lot to a lot of
people out there who are suffering from
that stuff and yeah he was just really
raw and honest so it's important for him
to to show that side because we wouldn't
assume that you know sometimes you watch
somebody you're like oh no he's a big
tough guy like you know but he's just
soft you know has a soft side and I'm
glad that he shared that story because
someone out there is going to benefit
from that you know amen uh Brandi D
loved him on The Magicians do you have a
favorite moment from filming that series
and by the way was there a lot of drama
in that series I didn't have a lot of
drama I didn't see a lot of drama I had
a wonderful time
you looked at me like holy [ __ ] I mean
the show's over now you know the show's
over
um I I think I came into a already
I came into a a steam train already like
in full motion if that makes sense so
when I came set I I had a lovely time
like I had a lot of time everyone every
customer was lovely to me
um whether people have like you know
quorums or something or favorites or
whatnot
um I've noticed that for me
if it doesn't uh and tell anything to do
with me like it's like oh then you know
it's fine as long as it doesn't affect
me
dead that sounds terrible no because the
first person I met on set was hail and
Hale and I are friends to this I call
them he's a nice guy super nice guy uh
we just we just gelled well you know and
uh summer was a second person and to
this days talk to Summer
um and everyone I met has been lovely
um and lovely to me and they've had a
great you know I think it's hard because
they're all in the same age range and um
I think there's discrepancies of like
um tears you know like who like me the
lead who's the lead who's not and that's
such an ensemble show but there is leads
you know right and there is leads and
whatnot but uh they made me feel
comfortable and that's all I can say is
they made me always feel comfortable
okay um but I would hear as any set you
know I think always but uh uh but yeah
what do you expect with just a castle
there was a little kid they're all
talented they're all young they're all
beautiful lovely you know there's bound
to be a little bit of Sparks or not or
negativity or whatnot in there that's
all you'll say that's all I say do you
have a favorite moment from filming that
series
um I did love shooting on the moon chalk
the the boat the um it was really sad to
see the way the character for my
character the the way they kind of um
wrap their their their human life form
uh because in the book he dies very
differently and in the series
um we've dealt with something really
serious which is depression and he had
this key that kind of um this wonderful
uh character that seems so bubbly and on
point and always structured was holding
a deep secret which was depression and
uh when the truth came out um he jumped
off the ship and a dragon comes out and
eats him and when you go through the
belly of a dragon which is played by the
Creator Sarah
um her voice anyways uh you go through
purgatory and so you're not dead you're
in purgatory which is nice because they
saved him and they brought him back for
future Seasons but I that episode was
really special because I was like I hope
people you know this starts conversation
about checking with your friends yeah
yeah uh Christy what's your dream role
to play
oh my dream world to play
I'd love to do like a queer rom-com
Adventure or something like superhero
um or like a a villain you know having
really got to play a villain yet and I
think that'd be like juicy and I don't
know so maybe a rom-com a queer rom-com
or some kind of action-packed
um Thriller as a lead and I would think
yeah those are the good ones yeah I
think those are good he said no that
sounds good yeah
um
do you do you at all deal with any
depression now or any anxiety now or do
you mostly have it under control I mean
I deal with
anxiety just when it's like oh
scheduling and stuff that gives you
anxiety you know or disappointing like
someone uh gives anxiety but not severe
anxiety like it's just like something
that I can okay take a breather relax
you know and like deal with that but
I've never had issues with that not not
no not deep like that
um I think I've always overcompensated
by I always see the glass half full to
the point where I like have been in a
place where I don't even allow myself to
fall into a depression which means
because I know things get bad but at a
young age I chose to look at things like
things are bad but they could always be
worse you know what I mean and that
mentality of me never allowed me to fall
into a deep because I could have looked
at my childhood and like pretty had a
reason to fall into a d you know what I
mean yeah and I didn't and I look back
and it's only credit to like
kind of becoming your own chair team and
your own like no it's like things can
always be worse so yes things are bad
deal with them you're allowed to cry
you're allowed to feel and you do you
cry a lot I do cry I do cry and allow
myself to cry all the time and I think
because I did that as a kid and it
wasn't like manly
um I never stopped myself from crying
like if I want to cry I'm gonna cry if I
cry watching a movie if you tell me a
story and I cry I want to cry I'm gonna
cry you know thank you and that's okay
and I think because I allow myself to do
that it doesn't hold or Fester inside of
me like save it for later just don't do
it you know what I mean I don't do that
yeah because I allow my feelings to feel
in the moment I don't fall into like a
depression holding it back because I'm
not holding and keeping it to myself and
I think because of that for me I can't
speak for everyone else for me that
works and uh and yeah you have your you
have your bad days you know and have a
depressing day and you talk to like you
know someone or you talk to a friend or
a specialist or something but like it's
never to the point where
I don't I can't function or I can't
control you know I mean yeah yeah if
your father was here today what would
you want to say to him
that you didn't get to say
that I didn't get to say yeah because he
passed away quickly right well the thing
is
that with him I feel like I did tell him
all the time he knew he knew yeah and I
and I I always tell I always said I love
you which means dad or paw you know
um and so I think he knew I think I
would ask him more
um what did he see us because we
recently did a lot of things that were
on our bucket list to do with our dad
like he always wanted to be in the VIP
area the Dodgers game because he's the
one who loved Dodgers so much right so
we would always get nosebleed sections
because he could afford with a family of
like you know three boys one girl in
himself so you always buy those ones and
that alone was a luxury you know and so
I got to the place recently after his
passing where I was in the Jumbotron
at Dodger Stadium
with my name so I would ask him um what
did you think of that moment wow that's
beautiful
yeah that's amazing he'd be super proud
I think I know he was proud yeah
um this has been fantastic you've been
such an easy going fun loving guest
thanks for having me yeah thanks for
allowing me to be inside of you that's
what we say here on the show yeah and I
love your podcast and like you know we
have a Shadows podcast behind the
Shadows yes where can people listen to
that anywhere you listen to your podcast
behind the Shadows look for us on
socials as well follow us on Instagram
and Twitter and behind the Shadows
episode for every episode on the air
it's an episode of the podcast and who
talks on the podcast I do I'm the host
just you uh well I have guest stars so
every like we have Anup Desai who plays
the gene this season we have uh Fred
Armisen who plays The Familiar the
seasons on Christian Shaw's on it uh
Mark's on it we talk about Doug Jones we
had Doug Jones in the past yeah I love
it I hit him on the podcast it was
amazing so great he was so good as that
character what character was it the
baron the bear yeah he was so good so
fighting outside language and you get to
fight a lot too I see your choreography
and the way you move that stick yeah
people don't think that's me that's you
that's me that's crazy how many hours do
you work on that well the making of that
of that like they teach it to us in an
hour and then you have to go and go over
over and over and over so you learn the
steps and the stick was my idea which I
looking back I was like why did I
request like I didn't request it but I
recommended it and I was like what if he
went to London he picked up a new
character trade you know like our new
skill and they're like what and I was
like well he's always really good at
fighting and he's been away for a year
we don't know what he's in a year I
don't know him you know it's like he's
been away for a year he could have done
something for a year we don't know about
and they're like we like that what have
you picked up like you know some of this
work with stick and I was like I love it
so they talked to me really quickly and
then I had to go away and go over it
over and over I had about like five days
to like perfect it you nailed it and I
was just like like it's gonna live
forever so I gotta make it the crew
cheer yeah they were like the I remember
costume looking at it because we had to
run it for the first time with the cape
the trench coat that I wear right and so
like is this gonna interfere what kind
of move are you doing they didn't know
what the move looked like so then I did
it and it made like the flare of the
cape go out and they're like oh wow that
looks cool and I was like yeah I was
like it looks cool I don't want to look
an idiot doing it you know so doing my
own stunt things to take and and
everyone at the stunt group had Shadows
who helped out but yeah I love doing the
stunt stuff I really do I also love that
you're seeing someone who looks like me
be a badass on screen which is not the
norm I would like to count in one hand
how many times you've seen you know plus
size people kick ass and it's not the
norm so I it is now it is now and I want
to see more of it I love it thanks for
being here thanks for having me
[Music]
uh one of one of my favorites for sure
for sure definitely funny uh
forthcoming
just uh open book an open book I didn't
think there was anything I couldn't ask
this guy yeah
um so thank you Harvey uh thank you for
listening again if you enjoyed Harvey I
hope you'll subscribe and and take a
shot and listen to some of the other
episodes sometimes it's not even about
the guests you learn more about people
you don't know or you didn't know this
about
um
so yeah big big fan of what we do in the
shadows is great to see
the real person right he's just a good
dude he's a good dude it's a great show
great show I really loved it I love the
movie too didn't you
it's hilarious movie is epic just epic
uh top tier patrons get their name
shouted out and uh just join patreon go
to patreon.com inside you become a
member uh of Patron and uh it's a great
Community people are become friends
found friendships and other stuff and
it's uh it's really cool so patreon.com
inside of you become a member and I will
uh send you a message
here are the top tiers Nancy D Leah
asked Sarah V little Lisa Yukiko Jill e
Brian H Nico P Robert B Jason W Sophie M
Kristen K Raj C Joshua D cjp Jennifer
and Stacy L Jamal F Janelle B Kimberly
Mike e l
99 more Amira Santiago M Chad
d w w is correct Liam P Maya P Maddie s
Belinda and Chris H Dave H Sheila G Brad
d Ray H Tabitha T Tom and Liliana a
Talia M Betsy D correct Chad L Marion
Dan
uh r n and big Stevie W Angel M Rhiannon
C Cory K devnex and Michelle a Jeremy C
Andy T gavinator David C John B Brandi D
Camille s the chief Joey M design OTG
Eugene and Leah Nikki G Cory Katie B
Patricia Heather L Jake B Megan T Mel s
Orlando C Caroline R Christine s Sarah s
Eric H shaynar Emmett R Jeremy V Andrew
M zoduichi
77 Oracle Chris R Michael F Karina and
Michelle D Amanda R Amanda s gen B Kevin
e Katie red Stephanie K Lena 82 jorel
and Billy s
don't know what I would do without you
guys top tier
top tier patrons uh I think that's about
it
yeah you have anything you want to tell
me
no
no you heard it first from Ryan uh
thanks guys for listening it means the
world to me that you continue to listen
and support this podcast I hope you have
a terrific week be good to yourself most
importantly uh that's the most important
thing you have to be good to yourself
Learn To Love Yourself right man we
gotta love ourselves bro
um hey for myself Michael Rosenbaum in
the Hollywood Hills of California I'm
Ryan teys the way to the camera hey
thanks for listening and uh until next
time we'll see
[Music]